we are here we are surviving after the
bachelor finale I know you were tweeting
a lot of your thoughts how did you feel
about it all I mean it was insane I've
never been so shocked like my job left
the building it was absolutely crazy um
you know I I respect everybody that was
involved I know that that's really like
hard to go through I respect Peter still
I respect Maddie and like you know
standing up herself but like honestly
Hanigan is my queen now like she is my
queen
you tweeted that you felt like maybe you
missed judge Shanahan right yeah in the
beginning I saw her and I was like oh my
god this beautiful little model like you
know I totally misjudged her I shouldn't
have said any of her thought any of the
things that I thought but then at the
end of it I was like this girl is sold
freaking sweet angel she's gonna have to
fail to succeed that's it do you think
barb overstepped honestly she just
cracked me up and I was here for it all
things barb by the way I mean this
season's group of women has gotten some
criticism were they taking things
seriously were they just coming in to be
influencers and I wanted your thoughts
on that because a lot of people have
been talking about how Madison very
quickly got an agent allegedly after the
finale I mean I think that everybody
goes on the show these days to like
become an influencer or get followers or
whatever like that's your initial like
prerogative but I do think that it's
still an opportunity to where you are
open to love and you can't find love I
want to ask you if your girl Hannah
brown has found love because a lot of
people were talking about how Hannah was
recently hanging out with Tyler again I
don't even know what's going on with her
but I'm sure like she'll give me the
full tea whenever she gets back would
you approve of her and Tyler dating
again the fans want it so much how would
you feel about it I would be supportive
of whatever Hannah wanted to do I think
that's the answer barb should have given
us I think it was really high I think
Hannah is really hot so they'd be great
together just they're hot hot people
speaking up who's over here bring this
man in okay
are you madly madly tell me more yeah it
was love at first sight honestly we
haven't spent a day apart he's the best
ever he is so sweet to me we're so good
be together we're stupid were cute like
we're all the things the things wait
when was first sight how long have you
been together now Kohi remember that
okay sir look Hannah an actually said on
this season that she felt like Peter was
love at first sight and that got a lot
of people talking I love hearing this so
you guys believe love at first sight
like how do you know when it's love at
first sight I feel like it's just like
personalities like you know I I've had
previous relationships and like I've
loved these people but like whenever I
met him it was something completely
different like it was just like this is
my person this is somebody I never want
to not be around and I'm like an
irritable person and I'm like oh I don't
want to be around you you're irritating
me but with him I'm like I think that
was like the bonding factor between both
of us we both kind of felt that way
about our previous relationships and
things and and for us it just kind of
clicked and we haven't spent one night
apart since the day we met sleeping
alone is weird I mean and sometimes when
it's easy it's just great a lesson Peter
needed to learn I mean so is this just
an easy relationship no drama
yeah no drama of course do you like
bicker because we're both like you know
it's big personality yeah it's big
personalities it's just like us both
being stupid but we can also like come
together at the end of the day and be
like I was wrong like we both can admit
whenever
and we can work through anything like
it's really cool we can talk it out
we are somebody who has done two seasons
of the show now what did you feel like
you learned about relationships from
bachelor from bachelor paradise I feel
like I learned a lot about myself and
like things that I've done wrong or like
like qualities that I have that aren't
the best that I need to work on and like
I really focus in on that and it just
kind of made me more aware of like who I
want to be for somebody and yeah that me
some people were saying dummy for
Bachelorette but I guess your boot up no
never
[Music]
and are you guys writing this like is
this a forever love and kind of blown
away by this right now how do you guys
that within like the first three days
tell me tell me how you know like what
is it about each other's personalities
that thank you mesh so well I'd be
nobody both I've just been like for a
lack of a better word like players in
our past and it's like speak for
yourself
you know you need somebody who like just
changes your whole world and like how
you think about everything and like I
never want to be apart from him and
I don't know it's crazy like it's just a
crazy feeling that I've never felt
before I think the most important thing
for us is like our communication skills
honestly with anybody not even best
friends like she's saying like 30 days
40 days together like non-stop like even
after two weeks of being with some of my
best friends I want to rip their head
off and like even though like small
bickers that we get in we just work
right through them and it's like so
productive do you guys talk about
marriage stuff or you just kind of doing
the things you haven't talked about you
said forever like we'll get there like
when we get there
[Music]